Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW der dritten Ausgabe ich bins Tim Pritlove und nachdem ihr das letzte Mal hier über brexit unterhalten haben.
Mach mal das gleich noch mal genau hört schon
John John West wieder dabei und diesmal sparen wir uns die großen Erklärung wer du bist denn diese Sendung wird so ohnehin wenig Sinn machen wenn man die davor
gehört hat erstmal so als allgemeine Grundlage weil wir ganz gut denke ich
DECT haben wie ist denn eigentlich zu diesem ganzen brexit Wahnsinn in Großbritannien überhaupt hat kommen können was dann
auch bis dahin passiert ist und ich habe die Sendung veröffentlicht am 23 Februar Sonntag vorher haben wir es
aufgenommen und das war halt noch so naja mittendrin und,
ja dann kurz gegrübelt ok wie nenne ich denn eigentlich diese Sendung und habe mich dann für den Titel the deadlock entschieden und komischerweise danach.
War dieser Begriff richtig populär in der Berichterstattung also glaube ich habe es ganz gut getroffen.
Ja genau genau und deadlock dauert noch weiter oder wir haben eine Verlängerung bis Deadlocks jetzt.
Genau jetzt machen wir noch mal neuen Titel einfallen lassen schauen wir mal was dabei rauskommt,
ja schon also du bist ja nach wie vor mittendrin und mittlerweile auch immer zunehmend mehr gefragter Gesprächspartner auf allen Kanälen weil sie wo warst du jetzt schon überall.
Ja also ich habe an diversen beide Veranstaltungen in diversen Länder und Städte in Deutschland teilgenommen in den letzten Wochen Reden gehabt nimmt Cluj in Rumänien und in Stuttgart und in Frankfurt unter diverse Medienauftritte auch
in diverse diverse Länder also um.
Irgendwie Schlussfolgerungen aus diese ganze brexit Prozess zuziehen oder irgendwie das erklären also was sind dann die nächste Schritte wie gucken wie geht es dann weiter
also war ja das war meine große Aufgabe für den letzten paar Wochen meine Hoffnung jetzt ist weil Großbritannien jetzt ein bisschen mehr Zeit dass ich gewonnen hatte es könnte dann hoffentlich ein bisschen ruhige seine.
Hast du ein Gefühl also oder was ist dein Gefühl wie die wie dieses Thema in den
einzelnen Ländern in den du jetzt mal hast reinhören können oder selber zum Kommentar gebeten wurdest wie das so dort behandelt wird ist es ähnlich wie man das jetzt vielleicht in Deutschland erlebt oder ist es sehr unterschiedlich.
Also grobis gibt große Missverständnisse überall besonders die parteipolitische Lager,
verstehen die Leute in fast alle anderen EU-Länder nicht so richtig also warum können die Konservativen mit Leben nicht kooperieren also diese Frage taucht sie regelmäßig auf ich denke die,
in Deutschland die wirtschaftlichen Fragen sind noch sehr sehr wichtig vielleicht manche anderen Länder ein bisschen weniger also wie kann sowieso Mandy das britische Wirtschaft so.
Alle so Infragestellen also dass es so etwas sehr sehr wichtiges hier aber,
was überall ich höre ist warum haben die hier keine Lösung wieso dauert das Ding dann weiter warum mussten wir dann groß mit Handy dann mehr Zeit angeben warum kein Großbritannien keine Lösung dann finden also diese dieser an.
Ist ja auch nachvollziehbar aber es gibt jetzt zurzeit keine länderspezifischen Position.
Also in mein Diskus oder soll ich war leider in letzter Zeit nicht in Frankreich aus Rohdaten meine Frage da ist inwiefern also auf der Gipfel letzte Woche gehabt,
Frankreich so gegen den anderen 26 EU-Mitgliedstaaten die Frage ist das.
Ist das ein Frankreich weites Verständnis von den brexit Problem oder ist das nur so eine Politik Spielerei von macron Weimar, dann relativ hart gegenüber Großbritannien der hat
lieber Großbritannien mit einem no deal also ein brexit ohne Einigung raus aus Großbritannien länger Verlängerung zu geben also aus meine Sicht
das Gefahr für Großbritannien und die EU ist deutlich höher im Falle einen Audio brexit aus dem Falle einer Verlängerung aber marcourt genau das Gegenteil gesagt habe ich bin nicht sicher ob das wirklich
eine gesamt Französisch Position ist
oder Ort ist also eine parteiinterne Sache für Marco weil der wird sich auch so der große pro Europäer positionieren und der sich dann angefahren Großbritannien nimmt an den Europa Teile oder oder dann noch eine europäische Kommissare.
Oder vielleicht auch so ein europäisches good cop bad cop spiel um.
Ja vielleicht aber das Ding wenn wir müssen so tiefer einsteigen in in in was passierte in den letzten paar Tagen die Frage ist.
Wie gibt's denn eine Weg diese ganze Blockade so so in die Regeln irgendwie.
Was die meistens Staatschef verstanden habe ist.
Ein Mehrheit für irgendwas im britischen Unterhaus gibt's ja nicht.
Also diese dauerhafte Versuche von Theresa May ja ok Stimme einfach mal ein Deal zu.
Ja aber die die Regierungschefs haben nicht daran geglaubt und die haben vollkommen recht aus meiner Sicht es gibt keine keine Wahl Mehrheit für irgendeine brexit Variant im britischen Unterhaus gerade die Frage ist dann wie findet man dann ein anderes ein anderes weg.
Und dann diese andere Wege dann sind dann meine Unterhauswahlen Großbritannien Fleischer zweites Referendum
oder oder einer Einigkeit irgendwie zwischen den Parteien für einen sanften brexit besser geht davon aus dass ich Chance und dass sowas gelinkt sind dann relativ gering oder vielleicht ein Partei interne Urwahl bei der bei der konservativen
und Wiese Meydan mit sonst noch jemand übersetzen also die sind die möglichen Optionen.
Die Frage dann ist wie lang brauche dann Großbritannien um.
Anton diesellösung dann ausführen zu können.
Und ein Unterhauswahl dauert ein paar Monaten ein zweites Referendum braucht 22 Wochen da so mehreren Monaten und sowas morgen gesehen also hast du dann die Begründung gibt es für Tanja ein bisschen mehr Zeit,
und die können dann vielleicht dann diese seid dann brauchen um irgendeine Lösung zu finden.
Was wir jetzt in den letzten 24 schon gesehen haben da bin ich noch skeptisch also war die Debatte im britischen Unterhaus tuis mehr hat dann alles wiederholt genau wie vor Monaten also sie hat gar nicht gelernt.
The Mainboard.
Ja genau also ja Stimme einfach mal mein deal zu ninea im Moment mache sonst haben wir schon seinen Bruder angehört also ich bin da nie sicher ob ob ob Großbritannien in der Lage ist dann entweder aus auf diese Situation zu kriegen.
Aber was wissen wir das Wissen ist die konservative Hinterbänkler die sind sauer es gibt es wird eine Europawahl geben in Großbritannien jetzt am 23.Mai.
Es gibt auch lokalen Wahlen in ihn in viele Städte in England,
am Schorn 2. Mai und dann die Konservativen werden dann richtig Unterdrucks
bei Diesel bei diesen Wahlen also dann besteht dann die Chance dass die die die Tore sein OK jetzt jetzt ist es ja Schluss
may also und dann vielleicht dann die werden dann schwiese mehr setzen und das könnte dann ein Schritt sein Oma dazu.
Okay bevor wir vielleicht so in diese prediction der unmittelbaren und nächsten Zukunft kommt wir mal glaube ich aber erstmal ein bisschen aufräumen was eigentlich seit der letzten Sendung überhaupt passiert ist,
und ich will auch noch mal anfangen mit etwas was ich leider total vergessen habe zu erwähnen und was mittlerweile noch mehr Popularität erfahren hat also bis dahin schon war nämlich deine Diagramme,
du bist wann hast du damit angefangen.
Also diese Serie so im Januar dieses Jahr ja ja ja ja.
Oder noch nicht so lange aber irgendwann hast du das Gefühl gehabt so viele Optionen sind auf dem Tisch jetzt muss man auch jemand Überblick schaffen dann hast du da so eine Online diagrammtool zusammengesucht und damit quasi so Flussdiagramme von möglichen,
wegen die das politische nehmen kann und das sind sowie extrem also mit was sind ein bisschen einfacher da sind wieder total complete.
Er hat sich auch von Tag zu Tag und was besonders lustig daran finde es nicht nur dass man schönen Überblick bekommt über so die vermutlichen Option
manchmal sind ja auch welche gewesen die du vielleicht nicht drauf gehabt hast nutzt du die Funktion dieser Software auch noch Wahrscheinlichkeiten aus Zurich.
Und das heißt am Ende dieses Diagramm steht immer.
Das sind so die sechs oder fünf oder 410 Varianten auf dieses vielleicht langfristig hinauslaufen könnte eben mit bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit da muss man natürlich dazu sagen der Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung nur weil etwas eine geringe Wahrscheinlichkeit hast,
heißt es nicht dass es nicht auch passieren kann das haben wir ja bei der Wahl in USA auch schön gesehen da pfeif auf die Eltern ja dann auch im Prinzip auch solche Vorhersagen gemacht und alle so ja aber das hast mich vorher gesagt und doch habe ich vorher gesagt hatte halt nur eine niedrigere.
Bitte genau.
Und ich denke sie muss man das auch sehen mittlerweile bis Dubai Version 26 da gabs aber auch noch mal unter Version.
Ja hatte ich auch gedacht.
Ist viel Arbeit oder.
Ja genau aber aber grob was ich am Anfang viele Kommentatoren besonders übers haben so gesagt ja also,
nur dir wird sein weil es gibt keinerlei Mehrheiten im britischen Unterhaus oder November stimmt das richtig was singt die nächsten,
Entscheidungen in Großbritannien also ich hab da so gedacht okay was ist dann den nächsten die nächsten,
was ist eine Lösung oder wie hoch sind dann die Chancen wenn eine Entscheidung in diese Richtung dann ausgeht was ist dann den nächsten Schritt und dann ein Schritt nach dem nächsten dann dann dann nach dem anderen.
Und dann dann packe ich dann alles durch und schau mal was für eine Prozentzahl kommt dann daraus also das und durch alle diese Diagrammen nur die also brexit ohne Einigung war er dann an dem Allerhöchsten.
Nur eine 33 prozentige Chance also viele Leute Busse haben das mit so dreiviertel Chance Jack ich jetzt Moment schau mal in den Zahlen also unten und ich habe immer,
so gedacht so da angeschaut wie
sind die Mehrheiten in den Brötchen und Haus und diese Mehrheiten sind mittlerweile relativ stabil geworden also nicht so viele Abgeordnete echseln von so einen harten brexit
Kurs wann sanften oder von den sanften so einer Kuh Referendum Position also,
ich bin von einem den Titel von dem Buch motiviertes heißt predictably Russian of Honor release einer ist ein Psychologe.
Und der sagt auch was ihr rational aussieht wenn man genug Daten gesammelt hatte
kann man im voraus dann dann wissen wie gehe dann so eine Abstimmung danach oder oder weil ein Scheidung dann aus und das ist was ich dann so durch kariert habe und danach meine,
bei dem ersten Version von diese Diagramme gab's diese Schätze ich genau der oder die Diana probabilities nicht,
aber auf den zweiten g kam schon von den 27 Januar und ich habe dann geschätzt die Chancen auf einen,
brexit Verlängerung der ja auf 73% damals im Januar und was ist dann diese Woche passiert ein brexit Verlängerung.
Nicht nur einer.
Ja genau so eine längere meinte ich nicht diese diese kurzfristige.
Ja okay verstehe.
Also grob ich fand es dann sehr sehr wichtig einfach mal sowieso krakelieren also was könnte passieren und wie hoch sind dann die Chancen
und auch da drauf also mein mein mein Mann schaut haben habe ich das falsch geklebt oder falsch geschätzt also ich habe
dass du das einmal hat John bercow also eine III Mini verbaut nicht zugelassen also das habe ich mit eine 10 prozentige Chance
nur geschätzt aber das war schon höher als die britische Regierung weil die haben die das gar nicht geschätzt das auf.
Also zumindest die Optionen oder die richtigen Optionen nicht dann fast jedes Mal auf die Diagramme
und das hilft dann einfach mal okay wenn sowas passiert was sind dann die nächste die nächste ertappen die nächsten Schritte,
und wie geht das dann dann am Ende aus also diese Woche hast du die vorherige Variante Version 25 habe ich 3 Tagen vor dem Gipfel,
rausgebracht mit einer 40 prozentige Chance dass auf dem Gipfel die Treffen an,
ohne einen klaren Grund und das ist dann genau das was dann daraus kam also.
Diese dir gerne dass ich Vivi ich selbst denke also und dann.
Auto holst ja auch Feedback über Twitter ne.
Klar und manchmal war durch ein Mehrbedarf ist eine Zeile zwischen diesen hier und da oder die Chancen sind da einfach zu hoch oder so gering und es kam eine riesige Debatte werden an einem Tag vor dem Auftritt ist geht dann Entscheidung zwischen no deal
und die eine die einseitige Rücknahme des Artikel 50 Brief ist,
wie hoch sind die Chancen das britische Unterhaus eine Einrichtung in die andere Richtung dann bestimmt und dann haben dann Meinungsforscher und Wirtschaftswissenschaftler und Politologen sich in die Debatte rein gemischt,
und wir haben dann so geschätzte 0,6 Chance für die einseitige Rücknahme und 0,4 für no deal und das ging dann in die nächste tierkamm Version also meine Diagramme werden dann besser,
dank Denso Import von die von meiner Twitter Followers also und das seit das hilft ja natürlich,
und und und und genau dein Vorschlag von vor ein paar Minuten okay können wir PDF-Version dann kriegen ab jetzt wurde Teresa dann auch PDF-Version oder so,
also ich bin für solche Vorschläge von den Design her und auch so ähnlich also ich bin für viel Input.
Von 1,
Wendy singleman was ihr gesagt habt ihr im Moment mal so es ist nicht so klar zu lesen also die in diesen Version also mache ich so und so und dann ist es jetzt so von oben nach unten
ist nach Zeit,
und von links nach rechts aus auf linke Seite harte brexit auf der rechten Seite so people Quote oder Verbleib also das ist dann so eine Angst ein Ansons GEMA damit man da dann die dir gerne dann verstehen kann.
Na ja also ich habe auch gemerkt nachdem die Dinger so ein bisschen populärer wurden das sprach sich ja dann und wir um irgendwann haben dann auch zu Spiegel und so weiter alle angefangen mit Flussdiagramm.
Das bisher war immer nur so ja die können sich nicht einigen dies und das und mittlerweile geht's irgendwie gar nicht mehr ohne ne jetzt vielleicht auch mal ein ganz interessantes Modell für andere Krisen Systeme.
Jajajaja.
Gut ähm was wir letzte Mal auch rausgelassen hatten weil sich die Bedeutung dessen auch noch nicht so richtig,
zeichnete war der Abbruch.
Im britischen Parteiensystem wir hatten ja schon darüber gesprochen dass du generell schwierig ist mit diesem großen Parteien und das Vittorias und wie auch Leber so.
Also die Wahrnehmung als eine CDU oder als eine SPD ist aus deutscher Perspektive trifft halt nicht weil es eigentlich in viel viel breiteren.
Politischen Rahmen abdeckt und daneben von moderaten Zentristen bis Hardcore right wingers,
geht im Falle der Tories und bei Leber halt von der Marxismus Abteilungen bis eben auch genau wieder in diesem Punkt wo irgendwie die Tories anfangen dann gabs ein Split und zwar will ich richtig erinnere zunächst mal 7 leva ab.
Panda zu 8 was am Ende es bitte ist heute 8 Uhr es gab sechs am Anfang ein paar anderen dazu gekommen sind.
Ja aber erstmal so einen Kern von lever Abgeordneten die gesagt haben ok wir können jetzt bei Leber nicht mehr mitmachen.
Von also der erste Grund der genannt wurde war aber nicht brexit,
Zahnärzte Grund war die angehende oder andauernde Diskussion über Antisemitismus innerhalb
der Leber Partei oder generell Rassismus und weiteren Sinne das spielt ja auch schon seit längerer Zeit sind so Vorwürfe die teilweise corbyn selber gemacht werden ZW in der Partei als solcher
später hat sich dann glaube ich noch eine Abgeordnete von den Tores angeschlossen oder zwei.
Ja so drei sind aus dem Tores ausgetreten also es gibt jetzt elf Abgeordneten diese independence group.
Das war so eine große Krise für labour vor jetzt vor sechs Wochen oder so und da haben sie da gedacht wie viele andere Abgeordneten könnten sich dann an diese unabhängige Gruppe dann anschließen,
und seitdem.
Ist nicht so viel passiert die die Gruppe hat sich als auch Hass Partei mittlerweile registriert also gesucht jetzt gerade Kandidatinnen für das Europawahl.
Aber dann andere Namen.
Unten anderen am change UK heißt dass es gibt noch die offene Frage warum lohnt es sich,
diese Partei überhaupt zugrunde Neustadt sich an den Liberalen anzuschließen und das geht mehr um die die einzelnen Menschen die dabei sind also weil.
Die Diele braven sind so eine sehr alte Parteien mit mit eigenen Strukturen Mitglieder.
Und die die Abgeordneten diese dieser independence Gruppe gegründet haben die sind etwas jünger die wollen,
selbst so die Kontrolle für die Bewegung dann dann übernehmen besonders chuka und meine und küss lazy die ehemaligen Leber Abgeordneten und und Hardy Aalen eins von den ehemaligen konservativen.
Das könnte doch noch mittelfristig auch noch relevant sein wenn Theresa May von jemandem ersetzt wird aus konservativer Partei Parteichef dann besteht dann doch noch die Chance dass anderen konservativen wechseln zu den.
Independence Gruppe also es ist,
also wir hatten dieses Jahr großes Buch also das war so als System wichtig in den Schlagzeilen eine Woche lang und da hast du es sind sprechen ruhige geworden,
in den Meinungsumfragen auch also labour in den letzten Wochen kam voran in den Meinungsumfragen und die Konservativen ginge runter
Asus klar war dass die Konservativen hatten kein Plan für den brexit also wir wissen noch nicht wie groß wird dass der das Umbruch dann sein,
Line Dance in den Systemen.
Du meinst Meinungsumfragen für eine mögliche Neuwahl.
Ja ja irgendwann mal nicht mehr auch für das Europawahl also da da steht Leber gerade vorne gemacht also die waren.
Ja ja nee aber war Systems anders also was bedeutet kluge Wähler können dann die kleinen Parteien wählen bei einer Europawahl.
Fallers was ist emotionale ist also gegenüber den nichtproportionale System für das Unterhauswahl.
Aber die Chancen Europawahl
komme auf jeden Fall am Ende noch mal dazu wenn man noch mal kurz bei dieser independent group das sind ja jetzt nicht nur so totale Bagband schau also der von dir schon erwähnte chuka umunna,
der hat mit meiner Wahrnehmung schon gewisse Präsenz in der britischen Politik gehabt.
Ja das Ding ist der kenne ich seit Jahren und ich habe whats einen für ihn vorhin erzählt gebaut.
Ja
Der ist der ist aus Personen Sie professionell und sehr klug aber,
der ist nicht so der richtige Teamplayer also der hat der hat überleg mal als Labour-Partei Chef zu kandidieren gegen corbyn in 20 15 anderen Ende der hatte nicht.
Wie die richtigen Allianzen damals gekriegt um um erfolgreich zu sein also sein Medienpräsenz sehr gut der ist aus Peking gut gut reden aber die Chancen dass man könnte omim
richtig eine Bewegung bauen.
Da bin ich nicht so sicher weil das so ein bisschen so ein Einzelkämpfer ein professioneller Einzelkämpfer aber doch noch ein Einzel.
Und ist von den anderen auch irgendjemand erwähnenswert doch relativ viele Frauen.
Ja also dann also bei den Konservativen direkt vom Servertypen also Heidi Aare in so einer eineinhalb Gordon ist echt kein Budget sie ist in den Medien sehr gut ist,
super professionell und kommt auch als Person sehr freundlich rüber dann es gibt.
Hanes Supreme zakazna von Nottingham in C ist sehr kämpferisch also nicht sehr kompromissbereit aber ich sehe ehrlich und kämpferisch.
Und es gibt auch eine Ärztin aus einem Wahlkreis in Devin wie heißt die Frau ich erinner mich nicht mehr in die Name von dir.
Nee nee nee sie ist erst lieber die.
N coffee.
Nee nee nee nee nee.
Bluesiana Burger.
Luzerner Ex-Lover die Terroristen,
also würdest du setzt ihn also ins im Bereich unabhängig und was konservative Aussehen abhängig yaraladi Wahlkreis,
geliebt und und
hat noch ein großes Vertrauen da vor Ort also die sind sehr interessante Menschen gibt den Ex so finanzpolitische oder in Cinemaxx Finanzberichten Schwächen der Labour-Partei Chris Leslie,
ist ein super intelligente Typ nicht vielleicht arabisch texte Ethik aber der ist sehr klug,
Unterlüß Jana Burger auch xlabel also sie war mitten in diesem so Antisemitismus Debatte bei Leber hat selbst und wieso Antisemitismus geleitet
also und ja also die sind die Menschen die.
Etwas bewegen können also die sind alle interessanten Menschen interessant Charakter die Frage ist dann für mich ist was wir uns in die Chancen dass man könnte mehr,
mehr Abgeordneten zudem ist diese unabhängige Gruppe dann TAN zufügen was ist die.
Und wie bleibt das dann nach einer general election halt.
So oder so es lässt sich aber beobachten ist bricht was auseinander so weiter und und und unter normalen Bedingungen wäre es ja zu so einer Abspaltung vermutlich nicht so gekommen und ich denke das ist schon mal eine Botschaft für sich.
Dann kommen wir so ein bisschen darauf,
was eigentlich jetzt konkret passiert ist seitdem wir das letzte mal gesprochen haben also independent Gruppe gehört jetzt im Prinzip noch ein bisschen
davor hat es war eine Woche vorher das dass diese erste Pressekonferenz stattgefunden hat und der Rest den wir jetzt gerade beschrieben haben hat sich dann so in den Wochen danach schrittweise
jetzt ist bisschen ruhiger geworden aber dann ging es natürlich vor allem erstmal wieder weiter.
Den brexit und gleich am 23 Februar als wir die sendung veröffentlicht hatten dann gabs das erste Mal,
so Diskussionen von Ex-Minister oder Ministern sogar somit naja also vielleicht sollte man dann doch mal drüber nachdenken ob man nicht die EU bittet den Termin zu verschieben weil immerhin ich passe.
Da war dann halt nur noch ein Monat das für damalige Verhältnisse war dass du quasi morgen aber es sollte alles noch etwas enger werden,
und gleich am nächsten Tag hatte dieser melden aber angekündigt nee wir stimmen jetzt noch mal.
Über meinen tollen Plan an weil der ist ja letzte Mal nur der und populärste und populärste Abstimmung.
Adesanya.
Zeiten gewesen da geht sicherlich noch was und das allerdings dann auch wiederum noch mal mit zwei Wochen Vorlauf also am 12. März wo man sich wahrscheinlich auch schon dachte so,
jetzt wirds aber langsam wird.
Also Theresa May hat dann versucht den Zeitdruck über hören also wenn diesem zweiten meaningful varud das ging dann.
Mit einer 149 Stimmen Niederlage dann verloren also das war nur das viertgrößte Niederlage der Parlamentsgeschichte so ein schon ein großes RV feldwiese May.
Und dann sie hat dann zum dritten Mal das versucht deiner 29 März und dann ging es nur mit 58 Stimmen verloren
Renesmee hat auch dann so gekündigt dass wenn dieses Ziel dann durchgeht dass sie sie trete dann zurück und dann auch das hat nicht gereicht.
Wären diese wieso letztes Monat oder das ganze Monat von von März herrschte dann.
Also ein Gefühl unter konservativer Hinterbänkler wie können wir diese brexit.
Auftrittsplan übernehmen.
Weil ich klar ist dass Theresa May selbst keinen Plan hat und die Hinterbänkler wollten besonders konservativen aber er ein Gewebe auch dazu.
Wir haben verstanden ich gebe keine Zeit Theresa May so ersetzen außer dem normalen Weg so ein Misstrauensvotum erneut zu versuchen gäbe es dann ja nicht.
Tupperware jetzt mal unterscheiden muss zwischen dem Misstrauensvotum was ist ja schon mal gegeben hat aber was parteiintern war.
Ja also Parteien time das war ein Dezember sowas kann erst
mal wieder in Dezember 20 19 wiederholt werden also das ist jetzt Gegner nicht also ein Misstrauensvotum in die Regierung insgesamt also das wäre dann die die Option aber das Problem ist bei bei sowas,
der die Premierministerin hätte dann zwei Wochen Zeit um eine neue Regierung zu bilden dann man hatten diese Wochen zwischen diesem mini5 Auktion den Austrittsdatum nicht also statt einfach diese Richtung Misstrauensvotum zu gehen,
das britische Unterhaus hat so einer sich für eine andere Prozedur dann den Schienen ist die ungewöhnliche das war dann die Kontrolle von dem parlamentskalender übernehmen also normalerweise in Großbritannien die Regierung kann bestimmen,
was im britischen Unterhaus abgestimmt wird die Hinterbeine haben den See gefunden vier Tagen die Debatten für sich,
zu übernehmen und die haben dann mit diese Zeit,
zwei Sachen gemacht erstens die haben mit dem sogenannten coupable.
Eine brexit Verzögerung zugestimmt.
Also Cooper bitte Sie auf Yvette Cooper.
Super DIY die ehemalige,
genau genau die die ehemalige Minister von von von golden-brands Anderson erlebe Abgeordnete und die haben die sogenannten
indicativo zweimal ausgeführt also das war dann ein Versuch ok Venturis Mail keine Zustimmung im Bettchen Unterhaus hat.
Gibt es eine Mehrheit für etwas anderes also und das waren dann die Saison Mini dieser indicted und das haben die Ende März zweimal gemacht oder,
Entscheidung also falls gab keine Mehrheit für irgendeine eine Variante die haben ein zweites Referendum geprüft die haben einen Santen brexit geprüfter diverse müssen brexit Varianten geprüft,
also das bedeutet dass Großbritannien hat dann zuerst dann am 21.
März auf einem Sondergipfel dann zuerst eine Verlängerung von zwei Wochen gekriegt.
In diese Verlängerung von zwei Wochen könnte Großbritannien dann entweder den austrittsabkommen zustimmen,
und dann An-22 Maja austreten oder nicht also das ist wann wird das ist genau was wir dann gesehen haben diese Zustimmung gabe es dann im Unterhaus nicht,
deswegen hat Großbritannien dann auf der Sondergipfel schon jetzt vor ein paar Tagen am 10. April dann auf eine längere Verlängerung gebeten,
und die Begründung in die Unterstützung dafür kam direkt aus dieser parlamentarische Abstimmung
von Yvette Cooper also das bedeutet dass es Brötchen und Haus hat sich klar geäußert wir wissen nicht was für ein brexit wir wollen.
Aber wir wissen dass wir wollen keinen New Deal.
Wir wollen stattdessen bitte eine Verlängerung und die haben dann zu Wiese medan zugebunden,
um nach Hause zu gehen um sich für eine Verlängerung zu äußern und das hat unter Umständen dann am 10. April dann,
Brussel dann gegeben und das ist jetzt dann den Grund warum heute nicht in austrittstag ist und das wird jetzt auf dem 31 October dann Fisch oben.
Ich habe schon so einen kleinen Schock bekommen als wir den 12. April als Termin ausgemacht.
Also bei ich auch also moment mal so wie wird's dann seine somit werde ich dann so
psychologisch gesehen der so aussieht für mich die Hände meiner EUR Staatsbürgerschaft aber ja also ich bin dann entsprechend dann beruhigt natürlich also aber das ist gut wenn ich in dieser Vorgehensweise über das britische Unterhaus,
kann ich immer gut und Fisch reagiert aber wir haben,
dieses Prozedur und ohne diese Zeitdruck verstanden,
und haben muss man sagen ne relativ gut darauf reagiert weil einige von dieser,
etwas ältere Hinterbänkler Leute die keine.
Zukunft haben oder oder oder die hat die werden keine Ministerposten Kriegen in der Zukunft oder ninini Parteichefs werden dann okay wir sind jetzt in der Lage das Wetter etwas für.
Das Land dann tun
also wir müssen nicht so kurzfristig agieren oder nie so Partei motiviert hat ergehen wie einige andere Abgeordnete also das ist warum dann die Leute die hinter dieser diese Verzögerung waren waren dann Event cubason Ex Ministerin aus Label Seiten.
Meinex konservative Minister Oliver letwin auch ein Ex-Minister auch von den Konservativen Dominic grieve also die waren die die Leute die dann,
sehr fähig und konsequent da im im im und Haus gearbeitet haben um um um dieses bei Zipfel Verlängerung deines.
Mit Agenten.
Innerthann da sind noch ein paar andere Sachen passiert die ich ganz wichtig fand also.
Vielleicht noch mal kurz zurück also Mini Fullwood 212,
märz ist gescheitert war die vier schlechteste Niederlage die eine Regierung bisher im britischen Parlament eingesammelt hat danach gab es dann das war glaube ich dann wieder direkt danach gab es diese Note deal
Abstimmung im Parlament das war dann wahrscheinlich dieses Yvette Cooper.
Mir so etwas einfach eine Einbau.
Also dass man das machen will ne.
Ja genau die die wir wollen brexit fettsauger nein wir wollen keine Rutil also so grob die Meinung des Parlaments damit nicht bindend
also und daraus ist dann dieses coupable instand und das wäre das war dann binden also das waren dann die Schritte außer die die dir das war deine AM3 am4 sehen mehr sonst aus 2 Tagen nach dem scheiden des
S2 Mini verbaut da gab's schon die erste Abstimmung für eine Verlängerung.
Und die beiden deutlich 412 zu 202 das war schon eine klare Ansage oder merkte man auch schon so ein bisschen irgendwas bröckelt so ne was ich noch ganz interessant fand nachdem diese meaningful vote,
bei angekündigt wurde ist Leber ja mal so ganz kurz im Schritt nach vorne gegangen und hat so die Unterstützung für das Projekt
people's vote noch mal irgendwie so halt ein wenig bekräftigt es gab ja mehrere Wochen vorher diese parteikonferenz war das Anhänger außer
planmäßige Konferenz oder der EM.
Ja bei mir hat er nicht die so Entscheidungsmacht also nee also grob diese Spannung also.
Labour hat versucht irgendwie,
die Partei Positionen es gibt grob Chats kann man schätzen.
So viel Fünftel der Abgeordneten von Label sind für ein people's vote und 153 dagegen und bei den Mitglieder ist es mehr oder weniger gleich.
Aber kurvensatz will kein meaningful Flut und die Corinna liebeswalzer hat dieses Foto an und die Kopien Alliierten,
auch nicht inklusiver ihr Inlay Brita Soda sollte Parteivorsitzender so also parteiinterne Chef.
Und Leiber hatte dann so ein Position die sind für ein people's vote.
Wenn das einzige mögliche brexit ist Theresa May brexit Variante,
also May's brexit + people's vote ist okay.
Aber eine andere sanftere brexit wäre mit so ein brexit wäre dann kein peoples Volt erforderlich zum bisschen,
blöd Auflösung aber das war als Kompromiss getroffen um diesen beiden Flügen DERPART Reisebüro Egan und das ist dann den Grund warum man merkt dass diese Position von Leber Schwein also wenn es,
gebe dann die Chance für einen sanften brexit dann haben die dann weniger über peoples wo gesagt
wenn die Chancen waren dann Siggi Regen das an einen einen einen einen einen Sohn ansatzweise stattfinden könnte dann waren dann die Diskussionen von einem Pippo dann entsprechende lauter.
Und die Chancen sind dann die große Frage bei people 22 und zweites Referendum ist wie viele konservativen,
wären dann theoretisch für ein zweites Referendum also die Zahl an konservativen die die sowas wollen steigt
ein wenig so sehr sehr lang kommt sehr langsam voran weil am Ende.
Wenn die Parteien wenn die beiden Parteien können keine Einigung finden parteiintern für oder gegen einen,
was für ein brexit die dann überhaupt wollen vielleicht findet man dann eine Einigung zumindest dann in people's vote so organisieren also was ist nicht von dem Tisch aber
die Meinungen ändern sich nur nur sehr sehr langsam.
Erstmal merkt schon dass auf jeden Fall Leber da ganz schön rum eiert und zumindest die Führung versucht sich da so ein bisschen aus der Verantwortung zu stehlen.
Dann gab es ja noch die meaningful vote 3 die ja dann doch.
Sozusagen stattfinden sollte und dann ist was besonderes passiert.
Wo nämlich wahrscheinlich zu Überraschung von Theresa May und dem government der speaker of the House of Commons mittlerweile ein sehr berühmter Mensch kann man nicht anders sagen.
Jajajajaja.
John bercow abgelehnt hat dass diese Abstimmung überhaupt zustande kommt das hat du hast ja vorhin gesagt die.
Die Regierung hat es in der Hand den Kalender zu bestimmen also zu sagen sagen worüber wird überhaupt abgestimmt
das also anders als ihr z.b. in Deutschland wo auch eine Opposition malen Gesetzesantrag einbringen kann der dann regelmäßig abgelehnt wird aber zumindest diskutiert wird und seinen Termin findet geht das halt in UK überhaupt nicht sonst ist einfach nur so goverman aber der Speaker hat
immer die Möglichkeit hier noch eine Art Veto einzulegen.
Ja also grobe.
Zu bestimmen was über.
Jedes Problem informieren Großbritannien ist man hat keine so richtig nicht so richtig schriftliche Regeln von wie funktionieren diese Arten von Sachen es gibt zu dem Buch,
vsge also da drin stehen alle,
aliments Traditionen und diese so Traditionen ist während ein parlamentarisches ja kann,
ungeändert nicht zweimal abgestimmt werden,
so zwischen den ersten meaningful vote und in 2 Mini verbaut gab's ja ein Unterschied Waldwiese may hat am 11. März irgendein ja dass dieses notiere ich in Bergsdorf ist temporär mit Bus und verhandelt,
es hat halt wenig Auswirkungen aber das wird dann die Begründung das Note 1 und wo 2,
anders auseinander wo zwei und drei waren dann genau gleich hast du es gab keine Unterschiede zwischen dem einen und dann hat schon Berge gesagt hier im moment mal das geht nicht das ist gegen dieses Regel auf 1600 irgendwas aus Soße also tief in die Pfanne men's Geschicht.
Die Regierung hat an,
ein Weg gefunden die haben die zwei Teilen von dem aus von den verhandelt Vertrag mit Wasser auseinandergenommen.
Also einerseits ist es withdrawal agreement.
Haunting policy die Politik Generation also die haben doch so gesagt wir lassen nur den austrittsabkommen zustimmen lassen bei diesem Mini verbaut Nummer 3 und das ist dem Weg um diese Blockade von der von John Burke.
Aber das hat mich schon so ein bisschen überrascht weil es ist ja so dass intensitätsform zwei Dokumente und das eine ist vertraglich binden und das andere ist ja eben nur eine Deklaration aber es gibt ja unmittelbare Bezugnahme dieser beiden Dokumente aufeinander.
Ja genau das stimmt aber aber das war eine kluge Spielerei um diese Blockade von von Burger umgehen doch nicht gereicht.
Was wir sehen mit dieser an von Debatten also das britische Unterhaus brauchte unbedingt Reform also und das alle Abstimmung
finn.no nach so eine Art hammelsprung Systemneustart
also das dauert eine Ewigkeit oder überhaupt diese syntac TV zuzuführen die hatten keine richtige Prozedere dafür also und und und wie viel Macht dann John bercow dann dann hat der hat er dann auch an Mama wieder Einfluss beim.
Volland von denen ich erinner mich nicht an was ich an Änderungsantrag das war es waren das gleiche Ergebnis auf beiden Seiten,
und der kann dann zustande akzeptieren was geht und was nicht also der hatte eine enorme Macht in den britischen Unterhaus und das H,
normalerweise ist.
Er ist es nicht so um so umstritten aber das haben wir gesehen in den in den Netzen so sechs Wochen wie wichtig selbst geworden.
Der sollte komplett gleich sonst und Ei das,
Ja und Nein identisch ist das ist relativ selten weil ich jetzt gerade was das genau war das ist eine indicative Wort gewesen, vielleicht dann noch mal dazu.
Iris war für die dritte Runde von induktiver und es war da ne ihr genaues war
Boninsegna sucht ihr genau entsorgen Audi Garage Zauberbann Zeiten und dann aus dem Präsident Fällen aus vor mehreren Jahren mit sowas passiert der des Pike muss den
Winnies weitgehende Option zustimmen und der hat sich dann gegen mehr in Wickede Woods geäußert.
Ja genau also es wurde ja eh schon ganz gut ausgesiebt also diese entwickelte Vorzimmer vielleicht mal kurz erwähnt das Parlament hat sozusagen gesagt ok Regierung kommt ihr nicht mehr klar wir müssen jetzt irgendwie mal rausfinden was wir eigentlich wollen,
und da gab es eine riesige Liste ist aber acht verschiedene Vorschläge oder es gab halt noch mehr Vorschläge aber Achtung und davon ausgewählt an der Stelle kommt dann halt auch wieder diese Macht des speakers mit rein weil er dann quasi eigenständig,
entscheiden kann was denn jetzt sozusagen überhaupt ja zur Abstimmung kommt und damit natürlich schon eine gewisse Vorauswahl macht ja und dann.
Habe aber jeder arbeiten aber sehr wichtig aus dieser Art.
Optionen also obwohl es gab keinerlei Mehrheiten für irgendwas.
Was wir gesehen haben ist die einzige.
Oder gibt es die Konservativen waren überhaupt nicht kompromissbereit die Konservativen haben einfach gegen alles gestimmt.
Und daraus ist dann ein Problem für Tim Wiese May in standen also wenn man findet eine Mehrheit für einen sanften brexit ja das könnte man finden.
Das würde mehrheitlich einen Politik der Labour-Partei sein wenn man schaut hinten fahren also alle sanften brexit Optionen waren mehrheitlich von labour Abgeordneten und du.
Wäre das möglich nach dem britischen Parlaments Tradition dass ein konservative Premierministerin.
Macht was hauptsächlich ein labour Politik oder eine ein laserplane wäre nein.
Und das ist dann am Ende das Grund warum es wäre für die Konservativen lieber okay wir verzögern brexit einfach ein bisschen.
Richtig ein Kompromiss mit labour abzuschließen.
Aber die haben so gedacht moment mal also wenn wir das tun dann unterstützen wir die Regierung nach was hauptsächlich ein Labour-Partei polypose Plan ist und das wäre für die Konservativen dann einfach uns und Ex.
Auf jeden Fall war dies Scheitern der meaningful vote 3 und daneben auch das fortgesetzte Scheitern der Dickete woods
wo man zwar was rauslesen konnte unter anderem ist glaube ich der Plan für einen second Referendum war eigentlich das was am meisten ja stimmen
Gefangenheit und ich glaube irgendeine common common market custom ich suche eine Invariante hatte glaube ich die größten Unterschied zwischen ja und nein das war so ein bisschen so die populäre rin Varianten nichtsdestotrotz,
konnte man daraus noch keine klare Linie ableiten
und das hat dann die EU daneben auch nicht getan und dann eben dieses diese neue Deadline gesetzt die ja im Prinzip heute gewesen wäre also heute wäre heute ist der 12. April wäre halt der no deal
brexit eingetreten nur wie man natürlich als auch,
mitbekommen hat kam es soweit nicht es gab dann eben diesen Versuch noch mal weitere indicativo zu machen dass es eben abgelehnt worden sehr knapp eben mit dieser 310 zu 310 Abstimmung,
ja
und jetzt stehen wir so ein bisschen da und man weiß irgendwie nicht so richtig was eigentlich als nächstes passieren kann also.
Lustigerweise ist jetzt das neue Austrittsdatum festgelegt wurde auf den 31 October also Halloween,
Halloween brexit das wird sicherlich noch für ein einige Witze gut sein aber.
Jetzt hat sich die Frage was ist jetzt eigentlich die die Situation denn erstmal ich habe das Gefühl.
Irgendwie ist so ein bisschen der Knoten jetzt geplatzt also oder die Luft ist raus was ich genau wie es bis sein soll also vorher war so eine totale,
brexit 4 so oh Gott nur dir der Himmel fällt uns auf den Kopf also alles hatte so eine gewisse Bedrohlichkeit und schon nach dem,
ersten Termin der gefallen ist und auf jeden Fall jetzt auch noch mal nach dem zweiten.
Besonders anfangs Weine.
Ist es irgendwie ich weiß nicht wie würdest du das beschreiben.
Das Ding ist wir haben jetzt gesehen dass.
Die beiden sehr radikalen Optionen also know the Love eine Seite und die einseitige Rücknahme des Artikel 50 Brief ist das will fast niemanden.
Und dass die EU will nicht dass Großbritannien zwischen diese zwei radikalen Optionen eine Entscheidung treffen muss,
also liebe Großbritannien mehr Zeit zu geben bitte alles ein bisschen zu verschieben als.
Corset Anime richtig krass unter Druck zu setzen also das war die Entscheidung auf dem Gipfel vor.
Aber was heißt es will niemand also niemand im Parlament.
Niemanden unter den Staatschefs.
Aber die sind die immer in der Europäischen Rat die die sind die die sind die Menschen die dann doch eine Entscheidung treffen muss.
Ja aber Donald Tasca so der Vorsitzende des Rats der Europäischen Union macht ja immer wieder ein paar Witze und meint so naja revoke wär doch eigentlich auch keine schlechte Idee.
Ja ja aber am Ende der ist doch ein pragmatist der hat auch verstanden.
Das ist mir stehe dann das Gefahr denn wenn wenn wenn man Sätze Großbritannien unter Druck die können die andere Entscheidung doch noch doch noch treffen also.
Ich finde diese Lösung war aus Sicht der EU.
Sehr pragmatisch also ich habe eine etwas längere Verlängerung gewünscht also 9 bis 12 Monate,
war war die Diskussion am Ende war es doch sechs Monate wegen Druck von von Macao.
Was Brüssel verstanden hatte und was.
Viele Konservative Hinterbänkler in den Laden gar nicht verstanden haben.
Ein brexit mit einem Deal ist zurzeit nicht möglich.
Nach dem jetzigen Lager in den britischen und Haus wenn wir wenn Busse setzt Großbritannien einfach unter mir Zeitdruck.
Das ist keine Lösung er wir haben das gesehen schon im März das hilft ja nie.
Gibt dann Großbritannien mit heit und versuch dann mal irgendeine andere Lösung zu finden.
Entweder ein Kompromiss zwischen Leber und konservativen oder dann.
Theresa May mit sonst noch jemand ersetzen ein Unterhauswahl oder ein zweites Referendum also die sind dann die Optionen die dann möglich sind,
einfach groß mit dem Bus also gesagt ok Großbritannien hier haben wir ein bisschen mehr Zeit überlege doch mal was ihr wollt und dann kommt zurück zu uns,
Anfang Herbst mit den Vorschlag.
Und denkst du dass die EU eine Lieblings Variante hat.
Nee also das ist dann den Grund warum man also es hängt davon ab also grob Leute wie rote der der niederländische Staatschef.
Der wäre breit keine Verlängerung für zustimmen in Fassade.
Auf der anderen Seite war dann mal chromachron will lieber das Großbritannien jetzt raus geht aber ordentlich.
Und das ist dann den Grund warum er wollte eine sehr kurze Verlängerung bei der hatte Angst was für eine Rolle könnte Großbritannien spielen innerhalb der EU.
Wenn die noch Europaabgeordnete oder, oder ein Kommissar haben also die können mit,
alle Varianten zwischen was jetzt auf dem Tisch ist Ron ein harten brexit außer oder ausser solunion und Binnenmarkt.
Übersandten brexit Varianten bis zu rimane aber man unter ordentlichen Zuständen.
Die haben auch Bus hatte auferstanden so eine einseitige Rücknahme des Artikel 50 Brief ist könnte sehr gefährlich sein
was sagst du stört den ganzen Brötchen polig ins Parteiensystem also Großbritannien könnte dann
überhaupt nicht in der Lage sein Entscheidungen zu treffen monatelang
und so eine Situation also ich denke dass dass das war so eine reine pragmatische Lösungen diese Woche dann in in in in Bosse aber es gibt keine gemeinsame Position aus Tusk.
Position tust will dass Großbritannien doch noch bleibt.
Und ich brako sieht Animes einzugeben nur mein zweites Referendum so irgendwie ihren damit das doch noch gelingt.
Der doch großen Spaß daran die Briten zu trollen.
Ja genau genau ja aber der macht das auch nach einem netten freundlich Namen weiß er ja.
Oh ja sehr populär bei den Männern.
Also also man hört das nicht von von von Merkel selbst aber merke es wäre auch denke ich die Lieblings Lösung für 5mr Klasse.
Sollte Zeit an dieser Stelle noch mal kurz sagen warum es eigentlich zu diesem,
bisher genannten Daten kam ja also der 29 März war ja ursprünglich einfach die normale Konsequenz des
this also das ist quasi des angekündigten Austritt von UK da hatte man zwei Jahre Laufzeit und das war natürlich schon so getimt so nach dem Motto naja dann sind wir ein paar Monate vor der nächsten Europawahlen
bin auch raus und passt schon dazu kam es dann nicht dann kam diese erste Verlängerung mit den 2 Termin der 12. April,
also heute war halt so naja
jetzt habt ihr noch zwei Wochen das müsste ja wohl reichen so und das ist dann sozusagen diese Bedrohung was wir gerade besprochen haben so nicht funktioniert hat
die andere Alternative war naja wenn es dann doch noch zu diesem Deal von Theresa May schafft 22 April ein Tag vor den Europawahlen
jetzt haben wir den 31.10 und dann können sie ja TV Fragen ok Halloween war es jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht,
die Auflösung ist der 31.10 ist der letzte Arbeitstag von Jean-Claude Juncker dem Kommissar Präsidenten also danach.
Ja halbwegs so groß war das deutschlandweite 9 Monaten Frankreich drei nicht sie haben sich auf 6 Uhr geeinigt.
Ja gut aber das fällt halt genau auf diesen Tag.
Aber das Ding das ist da auch sehr pragmatisch weil die die Anhörungen für neue Kommissare finden schon Ende August oder Anfang September statt,
ja und die Abstimmung im Europäischen Parlament also was passiert wenn brexit noch einmal verzögert wird und dann diesmal Großbritannien
kein Kommissar hat also wir hatten schon diese Debatte könnte Großbritannien der EU bleiben ohne Europaabgeordnete am Ende doch nicht Europafahne findet dann in großen Teilen statt
diese Debatte werden wir dann wiederholen ebenso Ende des Sommers Anfang Herbst was passiert wenn Großbritannien keinen
dann Kommissariat warum geht das während eine Übergangsperiode oder doch doch nicht also.
Also rein rechtlich geht es ja wenn Susan Großbritannien selber keinen Vorschlag macht.
Mafia ja aber also so so gut ist oder so ideal ist auch diese 31 October auch nicht.
Das war so ein Messi Messi compl.
Ja ich sag nicht dass er sagt dass er ideale sie sagt nur wenn man sich jetzt mal überhaupt überlegt welche Implikationen diese Daten habe
na also weil ich glaube das hat sich auch noch relativ wenig Leute klargemacht erstmal natürlich die Europawahl heißt das Parlament wird neu besetzt
aber es wird ja dann nicht nur das Parlament Neubesetzungen die ganze Kommission also quasi die in Anführungsstrichen Regierung oder die die die die.
Den den Gesetzes Weg antreibende Teil der EU die Kommission wird dann neu besetzt und das eben normalerweise paritätisch eben aus allen Mitgliedsländern und da steht eben dann auch Großbritannien
auf Papier einen Kommissar Rolle zu Hause und dann muss erstmal sehen wie sich das dann abwickelt.
Habe gerade den Blick gehabt,
auf okay wie stellt sich das jetzt da wer will was auf Staatsebene na was will die EU was will das Parlament oder was will das Parlament nicht das
ja die Frage besser noch mal ganz wertvoll zu schauen wie es die Situation jetzt in der Bevölkerung in UK es gab,
eine people's vote Demonstration die je nachdem welchen Zahlen man glauben darf,
sicherlich so im Bereich der Top Five Top 3 wenn ich sogar die größte Demonstrationen ever wahr man muss dazu sagen die Briten sind jetzt kein besonders Demonstration freundliches Volk weil das ist ja eng und da könnte man sich ja auf die auf die Füße treten oder muss man die ganze Zeit sorry sagen also.
Also ich will die Franzosen werfen mit brennenden Autos um sich und irgendwie in England ist es immer.
Ja die beiden nicht ja.
Ganz ganz ganz aber war war cute mit anzuschauen und zwar viele Leute auf der Straße vielleicht war es eine Million ich will das jetzt nicht beschreiben,
parallel dazu gab es eine neue Petition wir wissen alle Petitionen haben in der Regel relativ wenig Wirkung aber immerhin glaube innerhalb eines Tages,
kamen schon vier Millionen zusammen nach wenigen Tagen war mir bei,
6000000 Unterschriften für eine Petition die im Prinzip gesagt hat wird mit dem ganzen Quatsch revoke article fifty und.
Dann wir machen.
Genau einfach zum Ende bitte und ganz unabhängig davon ob diese als solche keine Wirkung aber.
Das war natürlich auch sehr interessant zu sehen einfach mal so 10% oder was weiß ich das Elektrik ist was haben wir 35000000 also 25% einfach mal so aus der aus dem Handgelenk gesagt haben,
wir haben einfach keine Lust mehr bitte Ende Gelände hast du das Gefühl dass.
Dass das etwas ist was sich jetzt auch insgesamt in der Bevölkerung niederschlägt oder ist das jetzt nur die hohe Motivation der Gegner.
Ja so.
Viele viele Leute sein okay jetzt bitte schluss mit diese ganzen Spielereien obwohl am Ende die Bewirkung versteht jetzt besser worum es geht und warum brexit,
so sehr wichtig für die Zukunft des Landes ist also das,
bietet die Briten so die Schnauze voll haben von vom brexit kann ich auf jeden Fall verstehen.
Aber das Ding ist auch wir haben auch gesehen nicht letztendlich in den Meinungsumfragen das ist geht für die Konservativen ein bisschen schlechter und für anderen Parteien ein bisschen besser in letzter Zeit war das war unglaublich wie wie hoch noch die die die Konservativen waren in den Meinungsumfragen
also die Briten wollen.
Eine Lösung was für eine lösen wollen die Briten also wenn man schaut in den Meinungsumfragen jetzt gibt es stabile Mehrheiten für einen Verbleib.
Es gibt auch stabile Mehrheit der Bürger Design wir wollen ein zweites Referendum nicht rasant sobald 55% in beiden in in in in beiden Fällen.
Aber stabil also das bedeutet dass wenn man einen Lösungen will,
die beste und schnellste Lösung ist ein zweites Referendum im Herbst dieses Jahr so organisieren ja das ist wie man,
wie man dieses Problem dann löst,
also und das wäre eine gute und populäre Lösung und dann wenn Großbritannien bleibt diese ganze Spiele reinhören hören auf oder wenn Großbritannien stimmt dann doch noch ein zweites Mal für eine austritt
Großbritannien tritt mit Theresa May Stil aus und fertig
okay und dann wir gehen dann in die technische Info mentation vorne von von von brexit also ja also aber das ist auch den Grund warum in den Schlagzeilen heute ja wir sind nur jetzt zwei Tagen nach diese diese Entscheidung der Verlängerung in den Schlagzeilen
gibt kein brexit mehr weil alle brauchen.
Zuerst Ruhe und ein bisschen mehr Zeit zu überlegen was sind dann die nächste Schritte aber die Brötchen Bewölkung will jetzt nicht mehr hören vom brexit aber leider so einfach ist es ist es leider.
Ja na gut aber ich meine immerhin bewegt sich was.
Genau genau und und es bewegt sich was auch unser Abgeordneten bei den Parteien also
man könnte doch noch den Punkt erreichen das
Mitte Mai es gebe genug Abgeordneten die sich dann für ein zweites Referendum äußern also die Chancen sind noch geringe aber die Chancen sind nicht nur dazu ein zweites Referendum Dannstadt.
Was auch nicht so tolles ist die wirtschaftliche Situation Großbritanniens.
Hängt natürlich mal davon ab welche Statistik man gerade gefällt aber es gab schon einige Rückschläge
einerseits sind die Investitionen extrem zurückgegangen den die Zahlen jetzt gerade nicht auswendig aber es ist signifikant
vor allem die Autoindustrie ist extrem stark betroffen sind verschiedene Werksschließung angekündigt worden es gibt zurzeit keine Modell Kontinuität und das ist quasi der Todesstoß eigentlich für so eine Indus
und natürlich ist dieses ganze Note Deal Damoklesschwert da in der Hinsicht keine Hilfe gewesen
es ist extrem viel Kapital aus dem Land abgeschlossen so auf Banken Ebene da ist sie mir die Auswirkungen bisschen unklar aber gut ist es sicherlich nicht weil letzten Endes Großbritannien ja auch vor allem von diesem Services & financial markets
gelebt hat 25% glaube ich der Wirtschaftskraft hat allein nur mit dieser.
Canary Wharf und um wie andere Banken in London zu tun wird das wahrgenommen also ist das sozusagen eine Diskussion die schon geführt wird oder findet das nur in Schlagzeilen.
Ja zum Teil aber es gibt immer diese Diskussion ja aber inwiefern ist brexit dafür schuldig oder doch noch nicht
und besonders die die Autofirmen b die haben Angst
brexit aus Kunden zu geben weil die haben dann Angst vor Boykott im von vom Verbraucher oder das dann den von negativen Schlagzeilen in denen in den Zeitungen also.
Und und man muss auch grob sagen also wirtschaftlich die ist in Großbritannien doch noch okay,
also Coop som Arbeitslosigkeit z.b. ist noch relativ gering das bedeutet das,
was wir gesehen haben ist Assisi in anderen Länder der EU besonderes in den letzten paar Jahren so richtig viel besser geworden ist,
Großbritannien nächstes auf ein Plateau geblieben es ist nicht richtig deutlich runter als ob wir die für den Alltag der Burger nicht so richtig runter gegangen aber was willst du mindest auch sehen ist ist in inwiefern
kann die britische Regierung sich um etwas anderes aus brexit kümmern ja da gibt's Probleme,
was ist ganze parlamentarische Zeit und die ganze Alben beschäftigen sich nur mit brexit so was bedeutet das anderen Dingen der I could Bethanien braucht die die diese Pläne eine neue Bahnlinie 7 nach Manchester und Birmingham.
Der benötigte Reformen der Gesundheitssystem und Sozialsysteme die singen kommen überhaupt nicht voran weil beim brexit fress alles Rene nehmen in white.
Und zwar nicht nur bei so viel Zeit auf brexit selber verwendet wird dann weil sie Unsicherheit natürlich ist auch.
Ja genau online man weiß ja nie sterben und man muss auch
also die haben da auch es gibt jetzt eine Debatte die haben 6000 Beamten von dem zu normalen passen sowieso ein Notfall Posten für den no deal brexit Planung so rüber genommen.
Wenn diese Leute noch gebraucht oder nicht dass es gibt jetzt eine Debatte darüber also.
Teuer teuer war.
Ja genau genau natürlich aber aber man muss sowas auch zumindest jährigen habe verstanden wann man musst du sowas dann dann dann vorbereiten aber was wir auch dann Suppe dann gesehen haben ist obwohl jetzt eine Verlängerung von sechs Monate,
das ist irgendwie ja ok noch mehr sechs Monate und Sicherheit aber wir haben jetzt verstanden also brexit kann einmal verzögert werden es kennen heutzutage werden,
was bedeutet das also ich bin dann entsprechend ruhig geworden also wenn wäre ich mal wieder den Punkt Mitte September dass es gibt keine Einigung,
ja für verlängern doch noch mal und wie lange doch noch und dort noch also das könnte.
Irgendwie eine dauerhafte Lösung sein Großbritannien es und will noch austreten aber treten die Staus.
Sein wenn es dir wenn das irgendwie deprimierend klingt aber aber ich gebe keine Recht gibt keinen keine Begrenzung dass man Artikel 50 nur ein paar mal verlängern kann.
Es könnte das einmalige einmal im Jahr das habe ich immer ja ja okay wir verlängern dann mal wieder.
Dauerhafte Krieg obwohl ich keinen Krieg mehr gibt habe ich haben sich nie geeinigt dass sie nicht mehr in einer Kriegssituation sind jahrelang oder jahrzehntelang.
Nordkorea Südkorea.
Ja geht auch genau ja ja sowas ja vielleicht einfach friedliche.
Ja gut aber das ist natürlich dann nicht vorne for the benefit of the people also das ist dann sozusagen wirklich einen Zustand in dem glaube ich Großbritannien erlangt frizzy extrem leiden.
Ich habe das Ding nicht was ist denn so wuschelig Doppel sich schon irgendwie er so versucht den einfachsten Weg.
Und eine Verlängerung ist den einfachsten Weg,
es ist einfacher dass du verlängern also entweder raus ohne Deal oder einfach die einseitige Rücknahme des Artikels 50 Brief ist aber was wir.
Somit das ist dann den Grund warum ich bin mit so einer Länge von 6 Monate relativ zufrieden weil es gibt großwirt Anime Seite mit etwas anderes dann stattfinden könnte also für miese Mary kann nicht alles einfach mal immer wieder überleben.
Es gibt ein Lokal in waren den Großbritanniens treffen uns am 2. Mai Europe wardamm 23.Mai.
Es gibt die neue das neue Parlament Jahr fängt im Juni an es gäbe dann die Diskussion,
dauert dieses Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Node irischen die jupi und die Konservativen noch und können diese Idee sich untereinander so eine Reparatur die kommende des kommende Parlaments ja doch,
im Herbst dieses Jahr gibt die Parteitage von den von den Parteien also und dann Venturi smeraldas überlebt dann geht's noch das Gefahr dass es dir dann doch noch ein Parteien Tennis mit Misstrauensvotum
am 12. Dezember also kannte Riese mehr alle diese Schritte dann noch überleben.
Was passiert wenn die wirtschaftlichen wirtschaftlichen Zahlen noch schlimmer noch schlimme sind also das bedeutet dass irgendwas,
dann in den kommenden Monaten dann da dann passieren damit sie irgendwie anders,
ja also ich kann nicht einfach der Fall sein dass alles bleibt gleich und Großbritannien braucht dann nur noch Zeit.
Was ist mit mein Haupt euch kann also ich habe es grob geschätzt auf meine Diagramme also ich gehe davon aus dass die Chance das turizem er ja als Parteichef ersetzt wird
oder dass ein Unterhauswahl stattfindet sind jetzt,
viel höher geworden die Chancen mit in den Weg zu einem sanften brexit oder ein zweites Referendum sind dann relativ gering.
Jetzt steht ja als nächstes die Europawahl an,
sonst schon erwähnt und ich finde das in gewisser Hinsicht extrem spannend nicht nur weil natürlich überhaupt das Parlament dann neu besetzt wird sondern weil jetzt auf eine lustige Art und Weise
die mega skeptischen,
tippen die meega.eu skeptischen Briten jetzt eigentlich das einzige Land in Europa sind was gerade so eine total vitalisiertes pro europäische Bewegung in der Bevölkerung hat,
meine Erwartung wäre dass das dazu führt dass die Wahlbeteiligung dieser Leute extrem hoch ausfällt und ich glaube die Wahlbeteiligung war bisher immer.
Extrem schlecht in Großbritannien andererseits.
Klar es wird so lieber geben die immer noch total durchdreht aber ich glaube diese Mobilisierung durch die rechte und für das Thema brexit die ist irgendwie auch ein wenig verpufft.
Was sind so deine Erwartung wäre jetzt profitieren kann also sowohl im Pro versus contra EU Lager und wie sieht vor allem das pro-eu Lagerhaus wer kann davon profitieren.
Es sehr schwierig weil wenn man schaut in den Meinungsumfragen gerade auf Meinungsumfragen für eine Europawahl da ist es wie Meinungsumfragen können Unterhauswahl,
labour zuerst an die Konservativen und dann alle anderen weiter hinter aber was darf habe ich.
Angst dass die Briten haben nicht so richtig verstanden dass bei einer Hose war dieses var System ist proportional,
das bedeutet dass Europäer können dann für eine richtige pro europäische Partei dann dann dann dann dann stimmen grünen Liberalen oder dieser change UK also die unabhängigen.
Oder Scottish National Park.
Autoführerschein partytasche schaust du die sind in Schottland meine Meinung zum Falkenhorst noch stark oder sogar die walisischen Regionen essen.
Bei den Konservativen ist es dann natürlich dir schwierig also was für eine Position vertreten die Konservativen also eins von der bekanntesten Konservativen im Europäischen Parlament ist schaut sammelt und es pro Europäer also
zieht er noch an.
Wir wissen zumindest das alles von den stärksten brexit Befürworter bei den Tod im Europäischen Parlament Campbell bannerman der ist der hat sich entschieden nicht anzutreten.
Bei der Labour-Partei dagegen der der der bekannteste labour Abgeordneter in den letzten paar Jahren ist SAP ganz der ist eine Junge aus London und des,
über poi rupea der ist super guten kann es super gut gewinnen ca also wenn labour dann sagt okay also unser,
wir haben so keine Spitzenkandidaten in Großbritannien aber unsere Spitzenkandidat ist ernst eine so überzeugte pro Europäer.
Was heißt es gibt keinen Spitzen es gibt da auch eine Liste.
Es gibt regionalen essen es gibt keine nationale Liste,
das bedeutet dass jemand für diese Listen dann an aber dann in die nämlich nicht genau daran sieht 89 Regionen also es Arbeit gibt dir keine gemeinsamer Spitzenkandidat,
alle Kandidatinnen für das Team für die gesamte Partei es gibt nicht den jeweiligen Regionen Solisten Anführer könnte man Susa.
Ja okay.
Daher aber aber der Weg war der bekannteste labour Abgeordnete hat der hat auch so viel Medien arbeiten so gemacht ist dies diese Typ der Tanz in den in London
und der ist aber eine überzeugte pro Europäer
aber der ist dann deutlich proeuropäische als die offizielle Parteilinie der der Leyen Partei also das ist und dass du dann die große Frage ist wie sie dann,
ein Europa Wahlkampagne der Labour-Partei dann aus,
aber man muss auch nicht vergessen das ist fein 80% der Labour Mitglieder sind 17 pro europäisch also wenn ich wenn Jeremy corbyn versucht eine eine eine,
alle endlich eure skeptischer Partei Wahlkampf führen,
gegen den Interessen von von den eigenen Europaabgeordneten das könnte sich richtig sein bei den Konservativen auch ja weil die haben diverse Meinungen zu so Europapolitik da also,
es wird auf jeden Fall eine super spannende Wahlkampf sein aber wie die wie die mein wie das dann ausgehen könnte es gibt ja viele.
Vieles könnte sich ändern in den nächsten in den nächsten Wochen es ist nicht in allen Fällen, dass es dir für die proeuropäische Parteien.
Oder die sehr froh europäischen Parteien unbedingt sehr gut aus.
Wie schätzt du die mobilisierungs Fähigkeit dieser neuen Gruppe nein also ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen natürlich befinde ich mich da wieder in so einer Blase aber da ist so im Jugendbereich doch eine ganze Menge passiert hier.
Nicht besonders hoch weil Umland auch leider nicht besonders hoch.
Oder zumindest nach was wir wissen von wie Politik funktioniert in groß.
Politischen Parteien in Großbritannien Südsee gierigen also das bedeutet dass wie viele freiwilligen man Hand.
Ist Bayern Wahlkampf wichtig also inwiefern kann man Leute motivieren kann man Straßenwahlkampf,
ausführen dafür braucht man Aktivisten und,
die traditionellen Parteien haben diese Menschen die neuen Bewegungen nicht,
also das ist dann warum ich dann skeptisch bin da z.b. diese change UK dann guten Chancen hat ich gehe davon aus dass deine Robe weil auch die Liberalen haben bessere Chancen als das change UK.
Aber diese Parteien müssen dann
diese neuen diese diese neue Wählergruppen dann ansprechen können also es gibt schon Potenzial aber ich sehe nicht in unter detained UK Leute dass die haben,
die benötigten Netzwerke um überhaupt erfolgreich zu sein die werden vorhin kommen klar aber,
ich erwarte keinen riesigen macro mäßiges durch.
Was mir fehlt ein bisschen falsch verstanden ich hab mich falsch ausgedrückt ich sprach eigentlich mehr von diesem neuen nicht den neuen Gruppen die zur Wahl stehen sollen die neuen Gruppen die gerade versuchen aktiv gegen den brexit anzukämpfen und das Geld gestern Salzgitter best for Britain.
Utah state of Rock.
Ja ja die aber die werden die werden Leute motivieren zur Wahl zu gehen
aber nicht zu sagen okay unbedingt diese diese Partei oder eine andere Partei zu wählen also was bedeutet bitte eine pro europäische oder pures random Partei wählen ich stehe zur Verfügung.
Oder Dimension Vikings machen auch so liberal und grün und und Independence Gruppe sind gute labour es geht eigene Maßen hängt von den Kandidaten ab konservativen Fläche New Kids zu begleichen Kings wenn die bestimmt machen.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus dass diese Parteien werden darf dann sagen bitte libro oder bitte grün wählen oder so,
Deiters das halte ich für sehr unwahrscheinlich aber die werden was tun um eine erhöhte Wahlbeteiligung so zu schaffen.
Ja und ich meine die Aufmerksamkeit für das Thema ist ja nun relativ hoch das heißt
kann man ja vielleicht auch dann diese Botschaft hatte Dich mal rüberbringen dass wir es hier wirklich mit einer ja mit einer mit einem anderen Wahlsystem zu tun haben und dass das eben dann sozusagen auch ein zulässiger Modus ist.
Das wird auf jeden Fall die interessanteste Europawahl aber sein in Großbritannien zahlen achso ich überleg gerade könnte ich ja ein paar Tage nach Großbritannien fahren um das einfach so vor Ort beobachten
ich werde das Amt in Deutschland noch wählen nicht mehr Großbritannien aber aber das wird auf jeden Fall eine sehr umstrittene und sehr interessant Waage.
Ist mein nächste Frage schon vorweggenommen also du wirst in Deutschland wählen.
Ich werde in Deutschland leben ja.
Weil ich bin ich bin Mitglied der Grünen hier in Deutschland meine eigene Potion Zukunft ist hier und deswegen werde ich dann hier wählen und und nicht mehr dort.
Ja aber alle EU-Bürger wir haben noch die Wahl also wir können wir können wählen wovon wir herkommen oder wo wäre permanent wo wird permanent Leben,
ah und ich ich lebe hier in Deutschland dass ich werde dann hier in Deutschland.
Ja ich muss mir das noch mal überlegen wo ich.
Aber dass das mache ich sehr gerne System bei manchen Briten die ich in Deutschland kenne die haben noch einen besseren Kontakt mit mit mit Politik in Großbritannien,
meine eigene Zukunft WE ist hier mein Kontakt mit AUA rufe Abgeordneten ich bin schön schöner Tag mit Europa im Garten und aus Deutschland nicht mehr mit 1 € Paragon das rüttelt an ihren also das ist dann meine Entscheidung dann dann dann hier.
Aber dass er auch noch mal so interessante Gruppe EU Bürger in Großbritannien also sind ja schon viele gegangen aber.
Ja aber es gibt noch drei Millionen davon zum.
Genau die vielleicht bisher auch noch nicht in dem Maße gewählt haben und denke ich eine extrem hohe Motivation haben diesmal zu wählen.
Ja ja das stimmt.
Und natürlich auch keinerlei klassische Partei.
Mitglieder sind ja und nie und der und Brötchen Brötchen Parteien waren nie so erfolgreich diese weiter anzusprechen als ich noch in Großbritannien gelebt habe war ich in einen Ausschuss der Labour-Partei wo wir dieses Thema gesprochen haben,
es hängt von die Gruppen haben wir irgendwie was für einer Partei diese diese Menschen wählen man muss nicht vergessen das,
über eine Million Menschen aus Polen in Großbritannien Leben und ohne eine halbe Millionen aus fast eine halbe Million aus Rumänien.
Und diese Leute kommen hauptsächlich aus hungrig aus ländlichen Räumen,
die haben vorher vor die nach Großbritannien gezogen sind,
für relativ traditionsreichen oder konservativen Parteien gewählt nicht alle habe aber mehrheitlich.
Die Frage ist dann wenn die eine britische konservative Partei so sehr Euro skeptisch ist wie die britischen Konservativen gerade.
Die Konservativen haben fast keine Wählerpotential bye bye bye bye deutsche Gruppe aber anderen Parteien die dann
Poe europäisch arbeite an deutlich linker oder linksliberale sind wegen diese linksliberales die linksliberalen Linie die haben dann schwierig ist echt wieder diese Leute anzusprechen also das bedeutet das
obwohl es gibt eine Riese Interesse bei diesem Menschen genau wegen brexit,
für welche Partei diese Menschen dann dann dann wählen das ist eine sehr sehr schwierige Frage aber aber aus aber
aus meinem Britschgi hab Erfahrung ich gehe davon aus dass keine politischen Parteien richtig in der Lage sind diese Leute richtig an.
Na schauen wir mal was dann sozusagen die Alternativen sind weil sie einfach nur sechs Millionen Leute die mal kurz entschlossen sein revoke article fifty mir egal was da jetzt sonst noch ist.
Aber es ist besonders eine schwierige Entscheidung ist Unfall war die höchste Beteiligung an diese an diese Petition war in London.
Und 25% der EDV Service eigene Wahlkreis 28-30 näselnd.
Also die Frage dann ist aber dann z.b. die Leber abbauen in London sind und die Pro europäischen also als pro Europäer in London der oder die traditionelle links ist was will man da.
Wie man Leber weil die Abgeordneten sind gut und die proeuropäisch sind und wenn man eine andere Partei weil die offizielle Parteilinie der Labour-Partei nicht so besonders pro europäisches sind schwierige Entscheidung.
William Scheidung auf jeden Fall,
naja also das bleibt auf jeden Fall spannend das wird sicherlich auch einiges davon abhängen welche Leute sich jetzt eigentlich überhaupt aufstellen als ich dir gerade bei den Torres totale Probleme also wer wer motiviert sich jetzt mit welcher Argumentation über,
finde überhaupt keinen.
Ja aber bestimmt Leute die dann sich für irgendein anderes Abend irgendwo irgendwann in der Zukunft kandidieren wollen also die die die trinkt bestimmt an.
Wennigsen bisschen zynisch aber aber.
Ja natürlich verarsch will er auf jeden Fall seinen Job behalten ne oh man die hat ja seine neue Partei gegründet.
Ja genau also weil das sehen wir mal also seit die Zeit verarscht ist Rootkit aus UK passiert ist in einer deutlich.
So so rechtspopulistische AFD mäßiges Richtung gegangen und.
Obwohl verarsch so sehe Euro skeptisch ich denke das Verrat,
selbst desmaison Populist aus ein Senufo,
und der hat dann deine neue Sopro brexit aber wenig ekelhafte Pattayas den jetzt so rechtspopulistisch jukib gegründet,
wenn dann mal sehen wie erfolgreich diese
diese beiden Parteien sind oder finden die dann doch doch mal wieder eine eine Allianz vor der vor der Wahl also der Hand da hatten die dieses Partei gestern Nachmittag oder schon heute Vormittag zu den offiziellen
Wahlkampf Lorenz gemacht aber die Laden in den Meinungsumfragen jetzt so bei 45 Prozent nur.
Weil die Konservativen haben viele von den Pro brexit Wähler schon für sich gewonnen aber verarsch ist Botschaft ist mit die Konservativen waren offiziell für einen
die haben das nicht aufgeführt wie sind die richtigen brexiteer ist außerdem wir brauchen eure Unterstützung so was könnte das könnte noch gut an.
Also verarscht muss man wahrscheinlich ertragen im Europaparlament zumindest für ein paar Monate aber.
Handweben ihn einfach besser ignorieren können.
Jacob rees-mogg also da kann ich irgendwas auf der Opa war nicht aber wir haben dieses Programm im englischen die empty vessels make the most noise aus leeren Flaschen machen dass das meiste Lernmodus,
und so ist es mit medisan von Menschen also und auf Twitter also so viele Leute reagieren auf Rasen auf auf und schicke mich morgen ignorier einfach mal dieser Menschen.
Ja dasselbe und Deutschland mal ganz gut eigentlich ne tja.
Gibt noch wichtige Leute also wen hast du noch so gesehen die in der Lage sind so eine gewisse Einfluss zu nehmen auf die öffentliche Meinung Jenseits.
Seid auf der politischen Klasse also wenn wir hatten vorhin schon erwähnt Stephen Bray.
Ja ja ja diese super gute Papa Anti brexit campaign oder der immer voll im Unterhaus nee aber was.
Den hat also muss man vielleicht mal kurz erwähnt wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal gehört weil immer wenn du Interviews geführt werden steht da und wir müssen einem Megaphon und schreit den ganzen Tag stop brexit grandios.
Ja ja der ist ganz cool aber ich vermisse.
Das ganze britische politische Prozess ist wegen brexit zu.
Kik Geschädigte oder es in eine schwierige Lage wie.
Wie sehe britisches Politik dann in ein paar Jahren dann aus also Großbritannien Braut,
unbedingt neue politische Akteure oder Leute die aus anderen Themenfelder.
Zu den politischen System irgendwie kommen so alles von den bekanntesten brexit Gegner online zumindest ist der ehemalige Fußballspieler z.b. Gary Lineker also was für eine Rolle könnte er spielen.
Also.
Also wirklich ein kluger Typ muss man sagen ne grandios.
Alles gut kommunizieren und der ist auch recht freundlich oder der uns von der bekanntesten Wissenschaftler Bryant,
z.b. der hat seinen eigenen Fernsehshow ist er ist ganz anders in wie er Politik kommuniziert also wie können dann politischen Parteien,
ein Weg finden diese Arten von Menschen eins bin,
beim einen Krieg den Eindruck an so hat der deutsche Konservative Essex Konservativen in Balls gesagt hatte gesagt meine Hoffnung wäre das Jerry the maze Nachfolgers konservativer Partei
wäre jemand der ohne die bis jetzt.
Neue Minister war also wir brauchen eine tiefgehende Erneuerung also wir brauchen neue Einflüsse neue Menschen,
in den britischen politischen System aber dann dagegen kommt natürlich die Frage was für eine eine Interesse haben die Parteien.
Überhaupt Kontakt mir das auch schon Menschen aufzunehmen weil das begrenzte dann natürlich den die Einfluss von die Parteimitglieder werden die Parteimitglieder von labour bereit mit so keine Ahnung hat die Leber hatte denen.
Thermen.
The Comedian der David witzig Eddie izzard es die Partei zugeht.
Wieso große Hoffnung des ganzen lustig also den bringt dann so einen neuen Schwung in der in den Parteiarbeit und dann.
Es hat nicht so richtig funktioniert weil der der fahrschulwitze ich laber nicht so besonders seriöse KSK meine Partei mir geht nicht gut an und dann.
Das hat der Situation nicht so nicht so richtig geändert also die die Frage ist dann wie.
Wie bringt man so ein bisschen so eine neue Kraft oder neue Luft in den in den Brötchen polichem System,
das ist eine große eine große Frage für die Zukunft oder dann ganz Grund gehende rote theistisch,
die britischen politischen Strukturen sind ja kaputt und man braucht er jetzt letztendlich ein ein schriftliches Verfahren oder eine neue Lösung für macht Whiskey Schottland oder Wales also was bedeutet das
es herrscht gerade so eine,
Hoffnungslosigkeit oder oder oder keine Ansichten für die so kommt in Großbritannien auch wenn man eine Lösung für brexit findet.
Wie sieht die Zukunft des Landes aus also es ist einfach von eine Krise zu den Ex.
Schickst du das Großbritannien jetzt so insgesamt etwas empfänglicher geworden ist für,
Argumente auf vom Kontinent also man hat ja mal das Gefühl man mischt sich da besser gar nicht also gibt's da irgendwie ein outreach gibt's aber vielleicht auch Möglichkeiten Einfluss zu nehmen ohne dass,
wie viele als Verrat gewertet.
Ich weiß nicht ob einfach super was die Briten jetzt verstanden haben ist oder viel drin ist ist inwiefern Bridges Politik kaputt ist,
es ist ein Schritt zu zumindest zu verstehen oder so akzeptieren ok hier haben wir ein Problem das nächste Schritt ist und wo können wir dann Lösungen finden,
und dann Lösung zusammen mit anderen Ende der EU wäre dann vielleicht dann den nächsten Schritt also dieses nächste Schritt haben die Briten bis jetzt nicht vorgenommen aber Großbritannien wäre jetzt offener fur,
Ideen von wo anders aus als vorher finde ich ja vielleicht ein paar Jahren 10 WH sehen wir haben.
Wo sollte man denn hinfahren wenn man mal auf Tuchfühlung gehen will.
Wie schreibt man ein Verfassung,
geh mal nach Island die haben eine super gute und offene Beteiligung gemacht in die ganze Bewölkung wie man schreibt deine neue Verfassung pomocy sowas nicht gemacht für brexit ja was für einer brexit wollen wir,
wie macht man Bürgerbeteiligung und um um umso besser.
Anfahrt System geh mal nach Irland weil die haben aus meiner Sicht das beste war System in Europa Single transferable vote da man.
Wahlkreise damit man dann Block Kontakt mit den lokalen Abgeordnete noch hat aber das System ist proportional
also da das findet sehe dass das funktioniert nach einer sehr guten haben weiße,
wenn man will eine sehr offene und interessante politische Kultur ich finde sie interessant in Finnland soweit die da gibt's da gibt's was zu lernen.
Posekany muss vieles dezentralisieren also ausloten aus wo findet man ein gutes Regionalpolitik,
Fleisch in Deutschland vielleicht in manchen Regionen von Spanien bin ich sicher.
Also das bedeutet wenn man sammelt gute Beispiele aus diversen Ende da könnte Großbritannien doch noch was lernen.
Aber wenn jetzt Europäer sich mal mit der Situation in UK anfreunden wollen wo fährt man denn dann hin.
Um um das zu verstehen also.
Ja um oder uns auch am beeinflussen oder irgendwo helfen zu können also um auf vielleicht mal so einen Kontakt als habe es gefühlt dieser Insel muss einfach mal wieder Verbindungen finden.
Ja so da.
Beide Richtungen gehen.
Das fand ich immer traurig also ich war jahrelang Mitglied der Labour Partei in Großbritannien und und ich habe einige Sorge Kampagne Austausch gemacht mit,
schwedische Sozialdemokraten bis insofern sofabar Kampf gemacht auf den Straßen hindern mit ankuppeln Fachleute aus Schweden hat total gut geklappt.
Buddy System Demo vor ein paar vor einige Wochen,
einige grüne Abgeordnetenhaus Deutschland die Niederländer sind einfach verloren gegangen dann haben wir einen haben sich mit den mitnehmen den Prozess reingemischt cool also so was musst du denn machen weil die prodiac Euro Gegner,
die sind europäisiert als Dipol ropera also der Pfarrer hat an jeden aus Italien und Frankreich in alle anderen Länder nach London eingeladen um warum warum nur um sich mit mit mit diesen zu beschäftigen also das bedeutet
du hast man wählen geh mal dahin mach mal weiter aus,
EU Bürger in Großbritannien engagiert ich bei einer Partei er sollte ihm im Parteimitglieder schaffen sind für EU-Bürger in Großbritannien offen also es gibt keine Begrenzungen du das einfach mal also das lohnt sich um Großbritannien.
Wo ist es am wichtigsten wo man das ändern muss ist nicht in London ist nicht in die,
Universitätsstädten so um London auch das wird Cambridge breiten Rating nicht diese armen zum Start.
Es sind in den alten Industriestaaten und Indigo Städten im Norden also Manchester Liverpool live Newcastle Birmingham diese Arten von Städten oder sogar die etwas kleinere statt,
also die sind die Städten die woman
und und und dass die Region in Großbritannien die am schwierigsten von oder tschechischen vom brexit betroffen wird ist die Note offen also um Newcastle alsol an der Nordseeküste
mit der Grenze zu Schottland also das ist in dem Region was am Herzen von der brexit betroffen wird in Großbritannien doch noch aussteigen und die haben dann zwei Drittel für ein Austritt gestimmt also das ist,
wo man unbedingt arbeiten muss ja parteipolitisch lokal auf die Straße und wo man,
ein gutes Wahlkampf machen kann das noch eine interessante Frage war seit dem letzten Podcast ganz ein,
so ein antist heißen im englischen einen by-election so eine Nachwahl in in in meiner Heimatstadt Newport in Süd Wales war der alte Abgeordnete gestorben ist.
Und Newport hat mit 62% für den Austritt gestimmt.
Aber bei diesen Nachbarn seapro europäischer labour Kandidatin hat den Wahlkreis noch für sich gewonnen
was bedeutet das da das kann auch gehen das bedeutet nicht dass das die britische Wirkung reagiert nur
in Sachen brexit das auf eine anderes Politik ist doch noch möglich und am Ende die Spannungen in Großbritannien sind nicht anders auf die Spannungen in anderen Länder der EU,
das ist es einfach nur dass es britisches System ist so kompliziert ist wegen dem war System aber dass das die Linken,
Lotti vorher links gewählt haben das Teil sich zwischen so jüngere Universität gebildeter in Großstädten wohnende Menschen und Elsa
nicht Universität die bildende in Peine Städte und auf dem Land lebende Menschen also die genau diese Spangen haben an den doch in Deutschland oder rechts oder so in Städten lebenden
bürgerlichen Rechts auf dem rechten politischen Flügel oder auf dem Land lebende Nähe konservative vielleicht ein bisschen sehen ob komische Seite also alle diese Tendenzen,
die sind Deutschland gibt gibt's auch in Großbritannien,
das Problem ist dass das Prestige an den rechten Parteien und und und und Regierungssystem nicht an wegen den Briten war System also sei.
Habe ein bisschen Geduld für Großbritannien,
weil alles was gerade abläuft ist genau was in anderen Ende der EU Gott passiert.
Und auch wenn brexit stattfinde du willst nicht stattfindet Großbritannien braucht ein Jahrzehnt um.
Einen nur einen neuen ruhigen politischen Lage für sich zu schaffen und dann in Großbritannien außerhalb der EU ist,
und dann besuch dann böse zu der EU zu sein
das könnte sehr sehr schlecht sein also lieber ein bisschen mehr Zeit eine Lösung finden in Großbritannien bleiben kann dass es stört die britische Wirtschaft dann nicht und dann mit Geduld hoffen dass innerhalb von einem Jahrzehnt
deutsche Politiker eine neue Balance so Gleichgewicht irgendwie finde.
Extension for ever.
Verbleiben für ever.
Sehr vielen Dank.
Gut.
Ich denke jetzt haben wir das Update ganz gut geliefert ja mal schauen ich mir vorstellen wer greift das noch mal auf vielleicht.
Europawahlen.
Oder ja Anfang des Sommers oder oder Ende des Sommers vor dem vor dem märkischen Austrittstermin im Herz.
Alles klar vielen Dank und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören das was beim Kaffee ich sag Tschüss bis bald.